[Applause]
Thunder aah hooks he's in a reverie a
dream state if you will
don't hold it for that long it looks
creepy I've got the you know folks I've
I got to admit something I got a I got
the holiday blahs it happens at the
holidays occasionally now the economy
everything that's going on this year
worst holiday blahs ever so today I just
haven't felt like being Conan the
talk-show host you don't I mean the
clown who jumps around it makes jokes
for people you know today I just feel
like being real Conan and when I feel
like that I'd like to go to a place
where I can be with people who accept me
for who I really am
it's a special little place a place I
like to go a place I called Joe's
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Joe I'll have the usual no not you
again I thought you were working
Thanksgiving it's the bottle come on
yeah you're gonna ruin it again like you
did last year Thanksgiving sucks when
you're around last time you got a
completely plastered yeah we wanted to
watch the football and you made us watch
some lifetime chick movie marathon even
my mom didn't cry during fried green
tomatoes with you every night is ladies
night that no one thought it was funny
when you put on your pilgrim hat and
said who wants to shower with the guy
from the Mayflower
you made me heave when you jumped up on
the bar to show off your sweet drumstick
which you then dipped into the popcorn
machine which I then hate you jerk yeah
finish your drink and go you're not
welcome here baby your grave and you
better pay me for that popcorn machine
hang up your dirtbag slob the dirtbag a
whole slob jerk
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
haha
oh yeah I gotta be honest I yeah you
couldn't see that home I completely
wiped out
[Applause]
Wow okay I feel much better now take a
break come back he's an Hawk is here